she does look hard who needs some love
potions put a whole bunch of teenagers
on a movie set together and what do you
expect the harry potter set saw
everything from stolen kisses to some
secret and inappropriate crushes number
one there was a gryffindor who secretly
wanted a slytherin daniel radcliffe
shocked the world when he confessed that
he had a massive crush on co-star helena
bonham carter this was a pretty serious
one radcliffe even wrote the actress
quite the cheeky note that could have
been considered inappropriate it was the
end of filming for the entire series and
dan knew it was a now we're never kind
of a situation so he penned this message
to his secret crush dear hbc yeah it was
a pleasure being your co-star and
coaster in the sense that i always up
ended up holding your coffee i do love
you then what does it say
i can we can share this now i said i do
love you and i just wish i'd been born
10 years earlier i might have been in
with a chance lots of love and thanks
for being cool isn't it how bold dan
wow looking back at old footage you can
see just how giddy the actor is around
helena and he was lucky enough to get a
cheat kiss number two
there were a whole lot of feelings emma
watson and rupert grint loved each other
very much there is no doubt about it she
was a really good film however grin's
feelings for watson were a bit stronger
than we'd expected during an interview
with the telegraph he revealed he did
have a crush on her but that he was not
alone in that on set as for getting to
kiss her well he put it best when he
said i'll be honest with you it's not
something i'd say i'm dreading emma's a
pretty girl as for who has the worst
crush on her me or radcliffe i'd rather
not say but even despite the small crush
the fact that they were so close made
the actual kissing on set part pretty
weird we've known each other for 10
years so it was a bit like kissing my
sister
number three he may have forgotten her
name but she knew his robert pattinson
joined the harry potter crew when the
romances on set really started to
blossom and people definitely noticed
just how good looking he was in those
wizarding robes and one miss watson was
among them
he was always very
intelligent nice talented good looking
kind of had everything now that's a good
review though pattinson probably lost
some points in one of his not-so-smooth
moments on set when he forgot emma's
name who's this thing right next to you
everyone come on get my name right
what's my name you look at this twitter
name what's my name robin that's that
one that's that one famous this is plain
rude number four
so many crushes so little time she's got
an amazing face she's beautiful matthew
lewis had it tough on set he was hanging
around a ton of girls yet he was made
out to look far dorkier and uncool than
he wanted to be sometimes having to wear
a fat suit and crooked teeth on set his
circumstances made it extra hard when he
was smitten with emma watson he did let
slip in an interview that he probably
had a crush on emma for a couple of
years until i was 13 or 14 something
like that i mean nothing ever came of it
anyway it never went anywhere and how
did emma feel about it well
she knows about it it's not something
we've not talked about or anything but
ultimately the actor was just a pal to
her
number five
oh young love is there anything like it
emma watson's secret crush was revealed
a long time ago emma and i have always
loved each other really she had eyes for
a young tom felton the sweet onset and
sassy onscreen slytherin the moment she
knew he was her dream guy i walked into
the room where we were having tutoring
the assignment that had been given was
to draw what you thought god looked like
and tom had drawn a girl with a backward
cap on a skateboard and i just fell in
love with him the crush was the real
deal it even dictated what kind of a day
she'd have on set i used to come in
every day and look for his number on the
course sheet if his number was on the
call sheet it was
an extra exciting day their relationship
went deeper than just a crush though for
emma home was the one i could be more
vulnerable with nothing has ever
happened romantically with us we just
love each other let's be honest though
we'll probably be shipping these two
forever
number six getting into character wasn't
too tough for this actor who knew this
relationship had the potential to
actually be a showmance actress jessie
cave who brought all that love potion
wild lavender brown energy didn't have
to act too hard like she was wild about
rupert grint kate thought grint was
scared of both her character and her but
it didn't stop the actress from wishful
thinking sharing that i thought there
might be a link there who knows maybe in
the future it has been a number of years
and cave is now married with children so
we're gonna say this one probably won't
turn into anything number seven this was
the worst time to deal with a prank
we're throwing it back to that time that
alan rickman and michael gambin made
sure mischief was managed by planting a
fart machine inside daniel radcliffe's
sleeping bag
this was particularly unfortunate since
dan had requested he be strategically
placed in the hall to be near a girl he
had a crush on swim
in the deepest waters and unsurprisingly
that one didn't go anywhere afterward
number eight
that's not a bad review there was lots
of courtesy chewing gum going in my
mouth
katie leon got to do something that
loads of girls dreamed of and she even
admitted daniel was a very good kisser
and while she sometimes joked that he
paid her to say that we all know how she
really feels the two didn't practice at
all and even joked about having mints
before filming trying to make each other
more comfortable and that was part of
what made the actress really feel good
with her co-star i love dan to bits he
is so down to earth it's unbelievable
you would never think that he plays the
most famous boy in the world he never
acts like he's the star he's so well
mannered and he really cares about you
he's always asking are you all right can
i do anything
okay swoon much number nine joining the
franchise later in the movies came with
some struggles ivana lynch wasn't
worried about just one crush she was
crushing on everyone on the set of the
order of the phoenix unfortunately none
of her feelings were returned and lynch
was definitely bummed oh it was so
disappointing for me because i joined on
the fifth one i was on order of the
phoenix and there was this sense that
exciting things had happened in the last
movie and i just missed it
number 10 this one was for life there
was clearly a lot of love on the harry
potter set and felton has been very open
about his man crush on rupert grint
saying i have eternal love for him as
tom and rupert not as ron and draco the
love kept going strong even after they
finished their time in the halls of
hogwarts since a few years after rupert
grint was spotted wearing an i heart tom
felton shirt okay boys get a room
number eleven these two were meant to be
it would be years before they shared
some kisses and played a couple on
screen but a young bonnie wright was
still in complete awe of daniel
radcliffe the first time she saw him on
set and wished him good luck
to be fair she wasn't off pretty much
everything and anything at the time but
taking it all in and getting to be near
the boy who lived we would have been
feeling the same way
number 12. a different kind of crush and
these ones were intense in both cases
the actors called their time on set with
their work crushes some of their
favorite moments from filming it's no
secret radcliffe was a bit starstruck by
working with gary oldman he's a really
sweet sweet man so getting to learn how
to play come together by the beatles
with sirius black on set was a total
dream come true just a weird surreal
moment that i'll carry with me my entire
life for emma watson and all of us to be
honest helena bonham carter is a total
legend and lucky for her hbc felt
similarly she very sweetly invited me
over for dinner getting to work
especially closely when the bellatrix
actress had to impersonate hermione only
made the love stronger
we had so much fun love was in the air
even without spells and potions to
interfere that's for sure spending so
much time together in this magical
looking and feeling world is the perfect
setting for falling in love which one of
these crushes surprised you most